THEIR BODIES.
DANA.
>> Dana: MATT FINN, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN OHIO REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MIKE TURNER.
THE NUMBERS ARE STRAYINGERING.
THE GROWTH IN UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS EACH MONTH SINCE BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE SINCE JANUARY OF
2021.
A STEADY INCREASE, SIR.
>> IT IS HEARTBREAKING.
WHAT YOU SEE IN THESE NUMBERS IS
THE REAL IMPACTS UPON
INDIVIDUALS AND CERTAINLY SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
THAT WE SEE CROSSING THE BORDER.
THEY'VE HAD A VERY TREACHEROUS
JOURNEY.
ALL AS A RESULT OF THE FAILED
BIDEN POLICIES WHERE THEY HAVE
OPEN BORDER ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO RISK THE LIVES OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND TO SEND THEM UP TO
THE BORDER.
NOW, THE ADMINISTRATION CLAIMS
THAT THE BORDER IS SECURE BUT IT
CLEARLY IS NOT AS WE SEE THE
PICTURES.
OVER 2 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
APPREHENDED CROSSING THE BORDER
JUST IN THE PAST YEAR.
NOW TO GIVE YOU SOME PERSPECTIVE
IN SOUTHWEST OHIO AROUND DAYTON
1.2 MILLION PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THERE.
THIS IS MORE THAN PEOPLE WHO
RESIDE IN THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
WHO HAVE GOTTEN UP AND WALKED
ACROSS THE BORDER.
WITH THESE CHILDREN YOU SEE SOME
OF THE WORST CONDITIONS AND THE
WORST EFFECTS.
THIS IS COMPLETELY THE RESULT OF
BIDEN DECLARING IN EFFECT THE
BORDER OPEN AND WELCOMING PEOPLE
TO COME.
>> Bill: WE GET LOST IN THE
NUMBERS.
TALKING ABOUT UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN.
NO MOM, NO DAD, NO AUNTS, NO
UNCLES, THE NUMBERS ARE 267,000.
FOR COMPARISON, DONALD TRUMP HAD
10,000.
>> Dana: THAT'S A LOT.
>> Bill: IT'S A LOT BUT A
FRACTION OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW.
>> THEY DON'T JUST SHOW UP ON
THE BORDER.
NOT THEY ARE JUST TRANSPORTED
FROM THEIR HOMES OF SAFETY TO
THE BORDER.
THEY HAVE MADE A TREACHEROUS
PASS.
MANY HAVING THE MOST BRUTAL
CONDITIONS AND SOME OF THE MOST
HEARTBREAKING CONDITIONS.
ALL A RESULT OF THE FACT THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT
SECURE THE BORDER.
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE DECLARED
THE BORDER OPEN AND WELCOMING
THESE NUMBERS ARE THE RESULT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION CALLING
PEOPLE TO COME INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Dana: ANOTHER TOPIC THAT WE
WANT TO GET TO WE'RE FOLLOWING
THE STORY ABOUT THE PRO-LIFE
ACTIVIST WHO WAS ARRESTED AT HIS
HOME IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THERE IS A DECEMBER CRAP AN SEE
WHAT THE WIFE SAYS HAPPENED.
SHE SAYS THERE WERE 25 AGENTS,
LOTS OF GUNS DRAWN.
THE F.B.I. SAID NO SWAT
OPERATORS WERE INVOLVED.
F.B.I. AGENTS KNOCKED ON THE
DOOR AND ASKED HIM TO EXIT THE
RESIDENCE.
HE DID SO AND TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
WITHOUT INCIDENT PURSUANT TO AN
INDICTMENT.
SENATOR HAWLEY IS CALLING ON THE
F.B.I. TO ANSWER FOR MORE.
>> WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
UNEQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAW.
WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT PERSECUTION,
INDIVIDUALS PERSECUTED BECAUSE
OF THEIR BELIEFS OR POLITICAL
A-- I FILLIATION.
EVEN IF YOU ACCEPT THE
ACCUSATIONS AS TRUE.
IT DOESN'T JUSTIFY THIS LEVEL OF
AN INVASIVE, CONFRONTING ARREST
OR THE F.B.I. GOING TO HIS HOME.
MANY TIMES PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE IS A NON-VIOLENT.
NOT LIKE THIS GUY IS A
GUNRUNNER.
NO MAJOR THREAT TO HIS FAMILY OR
THE COMMUNITY.
THEY CAN ASK PEOPLE TO EVEN
SURRENDER.
THEY CAN APPROACH THEM IN THE
DRIVEWAY AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILY.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO ESCALATE THIS
AND MAKE IT THE MOST INTRUSIVE.
I THINK WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT A
ABUSE OF DISCRETION AND SOMEONE
BEING PERSECUTED FOR THEIR
BELIEFS OR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
>> Bill: SOUNDS LIKE THERE ARE
MORE QUESTIONS OUT THERE.
SIX WEEKS FROM TODAY YOU HAVE A
MID-TERM ELECTION.
YOU ARE FROM OHIO.
WHAT HAPPENS?
WHAT DOES AMERICA DECIDE?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY FED
UP WITH WHAT THEY'RE SEEING FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
WANT IT STOPPED.
THEY WANT INFLATION TO BE
REIGNED IN.
IT IS A DIRECT RESULT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICY.
THEIR OUT OF CONTROL SPENDING IS
CAUSING PAIN AND INFLATION AT
THE GROCERY STORE AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
AT WAR, POLICIES AGAINST ENERGY
ARE COSTING THEM MONEY AT THE
PUMP AND MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND KNOW THAT
THIS UNSECURE BORDER IS
RESULTING IN HUMAN TRAGEDY AS
YOU WERE JUST REPORTING BUT ALSO
AN UNBELIEVABLE EFFECT TO OUR
COUNTRY AND A BURDEN UPON OUR
NATION.
>> Dana: REPUBLICANS SWEEP IT?
>> EVERYONE WANTS THESE POLICIES
STOPS AND UNLESS THERE IS A
CHANGE IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE
WITH POLICIES THAT ARE UNPOPULAR